y
we've been talking football, it
was it was just such a fool's
errand and I bring this up
because some of the scuttlebutt
to keep it in football parlance
is that we've already entered
garbage time in this presidency
where a quarter of the way in
and there are loud
conversations being had about
2024 okay, one of them on the
edge of town is of course
Hillary Clinton who wants to
parade back into the town if in
fact it killed in the midterms
as some type of centrist savior
for the party.
If we were just straight water
cooler talking not inside
baseball people, we know in
Washington. I don't believe
he's capable of giving up on
the presidency, I'm not telling
you she's going to win it but
could you can see there's a
world where she's going to take
the pantsuit out of the rafters
and give another about that's
Yes, it will definitely come
off the hanger, I can't see it
happening. I won't guarantee it
but I can see yet how that
>> proceed let's say okay but
if I'm Joe Biden not want to
give up on this thing, yeah I
to sue yeah, I know, but but
but here's the problem for him
I believe if he if if if you
want to tack back to a more
moderate presidency. You know
the progressive movement your
party is not going with you
and that's the prom and I think
they've been trying to avoid
that for a year. I think what
else is so many people are
riding in suggesting coming on
FOX and
these are Democrats to a lot of
analysts like fire someone yeah
well who do you fire and
they're saying Ron Klain I I I
mean there was a big piece of
the New York Times yesterday
Brett Stevens writing about it
to get rid of clay and give
someone who is the equal
to Joe Biden he suggested
someone like Tom Daschle I
don't know if that's the answer
but I think what I'm trying to
do is keep a tourniquet on
this hole center left you heart
of the Democratic
Party and the progressive left
and up until about a couple
weeks ago, I think they were
successful they kind of what
they're moving into a different
phase of his presidency and
listen if I if I were Biden I
want to be a success. Yeah.
I don't want to have the l